well Saudi Arabia wants to cut oil
production a lot of speculation that
this has to do with the Aramco stock
market debut how will boil cuts boosts
exactly Aramco's chances of a public
offering thank you for having me here
today yes in a perfect world of
reduction cuts would boost oil prices
and this will be warmly received by
Ramco however we do not live in a
perfect world I believed in the
short-term 400 and babo production cut
on top of the existing ones has the
potential to elevate oil prices but in
the medium to longer term any gains will
be limited by demand side dynamics and
of course open US shale firstly we have
to keep in mind that us your production
has actually jumped to a record 12 point
four six million barrels a day which is
renewing over supply concerns at the
same time we have trade drama between
the two largest energy consumers in the
world so this is fueling concerns of a
demand for crude oil and when we add
this on top of this as well
even if anything goes through on a
production column we still need to put
Moscow Moscow actually adopted a
hard-line stance towards any production
code so which means together just
believe this is a short term it's a bit
complicated it is fixed to a longer term
problem yeah the lianca oil floatation
is you to happen on December 5th on the
same day that OPEC the Organization of
countries that export and produce oil
are meeting in Vienna can the Saudis the
question is convince other producers
like Russia
you mentioned Russia and Nigeria also to
deepen cuts what what leverage do they
have we just need to look at the
shifting dynamics of the oil markets and
your favorable global macro you can make
conditions and we already have an answer
to your question and well Saudi Arabia
can push on OPEC members we have to keep
in mind that many of these energy
producing members have been influenced
by trade developments for example if you
look at Nigeria's economy we know that
Nigeria agreed
keep production captive and 1.77 four
million barrels a day but if you look at
the ports
they build pumping well above 1.8
million barrels a day
and 2020 budget shows that they want to
pump about 2.1 million barrels a day so
when we understand how trade
developments are negatively impact in
many emerging market currencies
especially OPEC producers and there's
only so much Saudi Arabia can do before
threatening to pour the OPEC deal apart
the ambition for the Aramco IPO has
scaled back considerably since 2016 how
much do you expect Aramco to fetch on
its market debut our investors more
confident about it now this is a very
complicated question which many people
do not know the answer to but what my
what my conclusion to this is I think it
will be really influenced on how the
OPEC meeting goes as I said there's two
things that could happen could either
see in a production car dole elevate all
prices which would be very good for a
mom CO or OPEC or could just end up
extending the current production cut
which would see your process push lower
and it could have impact the IPO okay
thank you so much for speaking to us
about this we appreciate your insight
look man Auto nuga senior research
analyst at FX TM live there from London
thank you very much for your time